si es el día de martin luther king acá
en eeuu es festivo se esperan marchas
desfiles se espera también una caravana
de carros y otros actos alrededor de la
ciudad lo que le preocupa a la alcaldesa
muriel va a ser es precisamente que en
estos eventos haya saboteo
enfrentamientos y es que efectivamente
aquí en el centro de la ciudad las cosas
están calmadas hay mucha seguridad como
lo vemos atrás camiones carros de
policía muchas guardias de seguridad de
mucha guardia nacional son más de 25 mil
hombres desplegados por toda la ciudad y
lo que dice la alcaldesa es que le
preocupan estos ataques en otros lugares
de la ciudad además pues tanto ervey
como otras empresas privadas han
asegurado que están haciendo
verificaciones de seguridad aún más
exhaustas a las personas que se hospedan
en los hoteles que alquilan carros o que
alquilan inmuebles precisamente para
evitar que terroristas domésticos
simpatizantes extremos de donald trump
lleguen a la ciudad hacer desmanes ayer
fue arrestado
acá en el centro de washington una
persona que estaba armada con munición
cuando se le preguntó por qué había
traído el arma al distrito de columbia
que es ilegal dijo que simplemente
estaba perdido pero esto preocupa
precisamente porque se siguen convocando
en redes sociales marchas violentas de
hecho el 20 de enero día de la oposición
se está convocando a milicia maga marcha
una marcha de milicias armadas el favor
a 28
cristóbal y de kamala harris debería
presentarse en el congreso para
renunciar como legisladora y poder
asumir el cargo de vicepresidenta
si después de cuatro años de ser
senadora por california y de haber sido
fiscal de ese estado también kamala
harris renuncia para convertirse en
vicepresidenta de eeuu la fórmula
vicepresidencial del presidente electo
joe biden como vicepresidenta kamala
harris era también presidenta del senado
será la ficha clave que pues se ponga la
balanza a favor de los demócratas dado
que en este momento hay 50 sillas de
republicanos 50 sillas de demócratas
será kamala harris entonces como figura
de presidenta del senado y
vicepresidenta de eeuu la que pues e
incline la balanza a favor de los
demócratas sobre todo de cara al
presupuesto que quiere aprobar joe biden
de 19 billones de dólares para hacer
frente al kobe y ayudar a los pequeños
negocios en su lugar el secretario de
estado de california alex padilla será
el que ocupe la silla de kamala harris
muchas gracias cristo